et pour en parler nous sommes avec david
xavier weiss auteur du break cité après
aux éditions barton jones merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
ça y est on y est c'est fait des années
qu'on en parle près des artères normand
cette fois ci c'est la bonne est ce
qu'on est au bout de nos peines on est
au bout de nos peines en tout cas on est
au bout d'un processus qui a commencé il
ya à peu près trois ans il ya un an
quasiment jour pour jour sur ce plateau
je vous disais compris mon nombril site
dur est effectivement ognier en est
finalement un vrai que c'est dur et ça a
été une confirmation politique puisque
boris johnson à une large majorité pour
le faire
donc il faut en prendre acte maintenant
sur le bilan pour le pour le pour la
grande bretagne je pense qu'il est pas
si optimiste que ça si on regarde les
choses en face
quand on va avoir une grande bretagne
qui va être éclaté avec une demande
d'audition de la part de l'ecosse de
l'irlande
que va devenir l'irlande on a donc un
problème institutionnel on aura aussi un
problème économique parce que le coût du
bric cité la préparation d'une réussite
de ces trois années de divorce donc à
l'amiable mais un peu brutal ça a coûté
l'équivalent de quarante sept annuités
de financement au budget européen
donc la grande bretagne a perdu en trois
ans 47 fois le budget qu'elle limitait
pour la pour la construction européenne
maintenant c'est un choix il ya il ya eu
un choix clair des britanniques il on a
voulu ce divorce
il va falloir maintenant l'organiser et
l'organiser ça va aussi prendre beaucoup
de temps parce que divorcé là
aujourd'hui on officialise notre
séparation narration et mais il va
falloir maintenant organiser les
transferts d'énergie
les trans elle des accords commerciaux
ce qui va y avoir maintenant des accords
bilatéraux entre la grande-bretagne les
etats-unis et la grande-bretagne russie
et l'europe où certains pays européens
donc on voit bien que toute cette
reconstruction c'est beaucoup de temps
perdu pour au final pas grand chose
c'est un pari politique gagner mais
c'est tape un pari économique qui a
abouti alors de négociateur en chef est
effectivement michel barnier
va mettre en place des négociations un
projet de mandat aux négociations aux
états membres à partir de lundi prochain
ce qu'on a le temps de régler autant de
problèmes compliqués en si peu de temps
alors non c'est bien pour ça qu'on est
déjà une période transitoire de minimum
6 mois en fait même la transition et
position paraît l'art est trop courte
bien évident et ça va se refaire sur
minimum quatre à cinq ans pour
reconstruire tous les accords bilatéraux
alors bien sûr les plus urgents les plus
importants comme ceux de l'énergie de
l'électricité puisque la grande bretagne
est dépendante ans notamment en matière
d'électricité par rapport à l union au
reste de l'union européenne
il va y avoir des accords très rapide
parce qu'il faut que assurer un minimum
même si on a divorcé il faut pas laisser
son ex épouse dans la détresse donc il
va y avoir des accords ou l'ex mari l'ex
mari voilà il va y avoir des accords
très rapide
et puis il va y avoir une reconstruction
très lente finalement est-ce que ça en
valait le coup parce que le quand même
la grande bretagne sait-on si on remonte
depuis 40 48 ans 47 ans la grande
bretagne avait une europe à la carte pas
dans schengen
elle avait pas l'euro elle avait quand
même eu un statut un petit peu à part
grâce notamment à margaret thatcher qui
avait réussi a finalement joué de sa de
sa personnalité vis-à-vis des autres
pays européens
il avait une europe à la carte très
avantageuse pour eux je vous entende on
se demande ce qui a poussé ces
britannique a voté pour le break 6 et
bien une volonté clarté politique il ya
eu je pense ya trois ans une
instrumentalisation de du sujet briques
cite notamment par rapport à
l'immigration qui est un vrai problème
qui est en projet toute l'europe
notamment mais pas à papa que la grande
bretagne mais nous aussi
l'allemagne ça a été instrumentalisée
pour gagner des élections
et ça a été instrumentalisée à dessein à
des à des fins partisanes politique est
aujourd'hui boris johnson lors du moins
il ya quelques quelques mois boris
johnson a remporté cette élection très
clair parce qu'il fallait bien en sortir
trois ans d'atermoiements c'est comme
vous l'avez dit c'est s était devenue
intenable pour tout le monde notamment
pour les entreprises qui avaient besoin
de savoir sur quel pied danser
sur quels accords commerciaux de nouer
est-ce que la place financière
ma cave et aux épices ans plus tôt à
londres est ce que la city va légèrement
se déporter on l'espère un petit peu à
paris beaucoup à francfort
- il va y avoir une recomposition en
matière de finances voilà il y à il ya
toutes ces choses qui sont devant nous
et qui nous réserve encore beaucoup de
surprises le feuilleton n'est pas
terminé
seulement on voit qu'il ya une fébrilité
michel barnier qui met en garde contre
le risque d'une rupture brutale des
échanges entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne dans le même temps boris
johnson qui menace de taxer les
européens les allemands sur leurs
voitures nous sur le fromage on est dans
sa un coup de poker menteur
on est sur un coup de poker menteur où
c'est en plus brute johnson il a il est
conseillé il a comme modèle le président
américain donald trump qui a lavé russe
voilà on sent on sent parfaitement le
l'inspiration je ne sait pas en revanche
si ça marche avec l'europe l'europe il
ya des traditions anciennes ce vieux
continent qui a des traditions
diplomatiques quand même beaucoup plus
feutrée alors peut-être que ça peut
marcher mais l'union européenne n'attend
pas que après l'heure après la grande
bretagne
ça peut marcher avec la chine parce que
vous avez entre les états unis la chine
des accords commerciaux et des accords
financiers tellement lourd là dès la
dette de la chine que la dette de la des
états unis et devant la chine etc
le rapport de force entre la
grande-bretagne et l'europe du moins le
réseau l'union européenne il n'est pas
forcément en faveur de la grande
bretagne et mais je pense que de toute
façon pour les jeunes sautent va
sûrement jouer cette carte du coup de
poker en permanence qu'est ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui finalement c'est très
important ce qui va se passer ces
prochaines semaines quitte un pour les
uns et les autres et ce qui est et ce
qui est problématique point inquiétant
c'est notamment pour la vie au quotidien
de dd franco-britannique de ceux qui ont
des échanges réguliers avec avec l'ombre
de ceux qui travaillent à londres qui
revit qui reviennent le week-end à paris
peureux il va y avoir d une vraie
période d'adaptation
ne serait-ce que sur un plan
administratif la wii et ça peut poser
non pas les problèmes mais des
tracasseries effectivement il va y avoir
un sujet plus lourd sur l'énergie et
puis ensuite à moyen terme un
rééquilibrage des forces notamment sur
le monde de la finance
effectivement on sent bien aujourd'hui
que la city est en train n'ont pas de
vaciller parce que
l'équilibré l'épicentre de la finance
est quand même elle reste à la city mais
on voit bien qu'il ya des grandes
banques comme la société générale etc
qui rapatrient leurs effectifs à paris
d'une part et dans le reste de l'union
européenne
donc la grande bretagne elle a gagné sur
un plan politique
oui une vraie une vraie partie sur un
plan économique et diplomatique
elle commence à s'isoler et sur un plan
institutionnel vraiment je pense qu'il
devrait faire attention parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez l'ecosse et
l'irlande qui sont légitimes pour
demander plus d'autonomie
est-ce que c'est pas finalement la fin
du royaume uni où c'est le début du
royaume désunis merci beaucoup et
terminera sur cette formule david-xavier
weiss d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france